let's go to our caller from the 64:6
area code caller from six for six go
right ahead
good good who's this and we're not on
speakerphone right I apologize
for now or not this is Randall from six
for six and I think I called him before
and I butchered my question and I wanted
to get your take on sort of a general
concerns flash issue let's do it
and I wanted to get your take so I would
say that the Trump just to put it mildly
the Trump administration has broken so
many presidential norms
and I wanted to find out I guess I would
say the pendulum is gonna switch is
gonna swing the other way eventually
probably in four years perhaps in eight
years in that the Democrats are going to
take over the presidency and I just
wanted to find out I guess what norms
that have been broken should be embraced
by the next president oh man I I don't
know I mean so Trump has certainly not
than not releasing tax returns I think
that that's one that we should we should
get immediately back to I think that the
norm of just speaking in a completely
disgusting way to media and people and
minorities in it like I think we should
get back to the sort of respect of the
office of the presidency I I'm trying to
think I mean I think that the one thing
I can say and I don't agree with the way
that Trump has done it but I like the
idea of separating the candidate from
the party orthodoxy
so with Trump it's just he has he
doesn't really know anything and he says
whatever he thinks people want to hear
but it's led to him taking some
positions that are not the orthodoxy of
the Republican Party I think that that's
good I just think the way Trump has done
it has just kind of been totally
haphazard and ambling around and feeling
around in the dark you know sure I'm
just I wanted to push you a little bit
about the strategy just I guess you know
as a progressive I I tend to be more
rule-following right I respect the in
but would you ever support progressive I
guess administration or Congress that
says we won't consider elbows to be
filled
they won't you won't consider oh boy
alright thought we were the call is
completely off the rails and I wish I
knew what he was about to say that we
should or shouldn't consider because it
sounded like it was going to be
interesting but that was not good that's
good first question though yeah I like
that I mean do you have a thought on
that like I would like any of the the
norm breaking things done the calling
out of interest groups like saying that
you guys are bought and sold by the NRA
right we never used to see that from
prior politicians now Trump is just as
corrupt as any of course president I
guess you could say but yeah at least
you know ostensibly he has the right
words I like that yeah I think I can
agree with that all right sorry to
everybody that we didn't get to I know
there's like a dozen people still
holding and many who have hung up
because they've been holding for so long
we will take calls again we're just out
of time for today and oh it looks like I
even got disconnected our phone system
going completely haywire we'll take a
break
regroup and be back after this today's
episode of the program is made possible
in part by coin schedule which is a
listing site for cryptocurrency icos
that's been around since 2016 and was
actually one of the first websites to
show helpful listing information about
icos where you can look them up by name
by industry by start and end date and
you'll get from coin schedule a score
for each IC o----
that can help you better assess how
careful you should be if you are looking
at investing in any particular IC o----
coins scheduled like me says that they
hate scams and one of the guys from coin
schedule was actually telling me about
how they do everything they can to weed
out the scam IC o---- so that they
straight-up don't appear on their
website and it seems that they've
learned a lot from doing this over the
past two years coin schedule is also a
really good resource for finding
information about upcoming
cryptocurrency related conferences they
also post crypto news and if you're
watching this on youtube I put a link to
the coin schedule website at the top of
the description to be
we're nothing on coin schedule should be
considered personalized investment
advice icos are risky everybody should
do their own research and make the
decisions that are right for them